If there's one performance law
that everyone should follow
it's avoid doing unnecessary work
I'm Joanna Smith
and as simple as that sounds
it can be a challenge
to find the places
where your code spends time working
on things that don't matter
Let me show you an example
so that you can visualize this
courtesy of overdraw
Overdraw is where pixels are drawn
to the screen by your application
only to be drawn over
by some other pixel
or view at a later time
Basically all that work you did
to color in the pixel the first time
is completely wasted work
A technique to fix this
is called culling
which essentially means
removing the code or situation
where you are wasting processing time
Not only will culling
take you from this to this
but will also help you
get from ugh to wow
Now as for actually fixing
your overdraw problems
try to isolate
the portions of the screen
that want to be drawn,
but won't be seen by the user
and then avoid drawing them
While I'm on the topic,
let's talk about drawing
Drawing objects takes time,
memory, and battery to perform
And if you can identify views
that won't contribute to the final scene
and avoid drawing them
then you get some
frame time back
like those objects that are overdrawn
when they're obscured
by another layer of objects
But you also want to avoid
drawing objects that are off screen
which is a complete waste
of time and memory
So for all those obscured
and offscreen objects,
learn to clip generously
But culling isn't just for drawing
Let's consider searching a database
for a user that meet several criteria
like maybe they live in Texas,
are very bald
and obsessed with performance
Unimaginative developers might
start to begin in the database
and search every user entry
for an address in Texas
for hair color that's not applicable
and for the use of the perfmatters
hashtag in their profile description
But that would take forever
Clever developers
would order the queries
to reduce the set of users
that need to be searched
for each successive criteria
such as isolating
all the bald people first
We've just culled
our list significantly
Then they could eliminate
every address without a state
or zip code for Texas
which leaves us
a much reduced list of users
Now we only need to run
the expansive search of their profiles
for the perfmatters hashtag
on that very small number of records
And what do you know,
we found our guy!
Culling is valuable everywhere,
from drawing the UI layer
to searching databases,
to using real time services
like location
For example, if your app alerts
users based on local happening
such as an Android Developer event
with barbecue
then it doesn't make sense to check
for updates to events
outside the area where the user lives
In all of these instances,
the basic principle remains the same
check whether something is relevant
before spending time on it
Because in most cases
actually processing the object
is more expensive
than taking the time to determine
if you should process the object at all
So take the time
to think about the user
and what matters to them
and then use culling to help you
focus on those things
which gives you
not one but two wins
Less work to do in your app
and a better experience for your users
Culling us a great start
but there's a whole world
of performance out there
So watch the rest of the android
performance patterns content
and consider joining our G+
community for tips, tricks and help
So keep calm, profile your code
and always remember,
perfmatters